Le problème, c'est qu'on nous fout la trouille avec tout,
on nous fout la trouille avec la planète,
on nous fout la trouille avec le climat.
Aujourd'hui,
y a des jeunes filles qui ont quand-même pas fait des
gosses.
Façon, on doit tous mourir en 15 jours, si on les écoute,
entre les règlements climatiques,
entre les
les gaz à l'effet de cerf et en train de faire l'autre,
qu'est-ce qui nous reste ?
Moi, je veux de la biodiversité,
je veux de la nature.
Mais ce qui se passe à chaque fois avec ça,
c'est qu'on se retrouve demain avec des interdits.
Dans quoi on va vivre demain ?
Est-ce que vous sortirez encore de votre maison demain
sans mettre le billet
dans 1 endroit où vous n'avez plus le droit d'être
en tant qu'être humain ?
Et ça, ça me choque profondément. D'ailleurs,
l'Europe a inventé 1 système extraordinaire.
1 système a brisé 1 seule chose,
la propriété, la propriété privée.
C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui,
vous avez des plangestions sur les territoires,
même privées, vous avez des airs protégés,
vous avez du réen sauvagement,
vous êtes chez vous,
et ben demain
on vous dira
ce que vous avez encore le droit d'y faire.
C'est formidable.
Moi j'appelle ça le col cause écologique.
Y a même pas besoin d'acheter le territoire,
il suffit simplement de voter 1 loi.
Vous ne vous dépossédez pas,
vous n'avez aucune indemnisation de quoi que ce soit,
mais vous n'êtes plus chez vous.
C'est ça l'écologie pulitique.